[拍手]
ああああああ
ん
[音楽]
uh
ブーブー r f
[音楽]
バッハ
おおーー
[音楽]
ん
r
rip
[音楽]
padi
プーペ
う
[音楽]
ん
car ん
ああああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
あなたは感動したことがありますか
私が思う感動
それは喜怒哀楽を感じそして心が動くということ
この現代社会様々な卑劣なことが起こり感動する心が失われているんです
どうしたらそういった感動する心が取り戻せるのか
今日は私の鎮静感を
お話ししながらお伝えしたいと思います
私は懸念コンサートがありるーマリエに行くことがありました
その経験といったらもう素晴らしいものだったんですね
友人と演奏会をしたんですけれどもその友人もとても明るくて一緒に楽しいコンサート
過ごすことができました
そして美味しい食べ物そして空気が違い
ルーマニア人の楽しい人柄
面白い人から私にマッチしていました
これまでの人生に
反射しました
先生は
なくなったんだよ
ある大大 p ロイホールの中でそれを聞きました
私が高校生の頃私は自分がどういった音楽をしたいのかそして音楽で何をしたいのか
そして社会の理不尽さに悩んでいました
そしてそんな時高校の友人がある大学の説明会に行きたいので私も一緒に付いていく
ことにしました
その時に出会ったのがその先生だったんです
タブ大学の説明会では一人一人霊数がをしてくださるんですけれども
その先生は初対面に出たにもかかわらず私のそういった悩みに素敵なアドバイスをくれ
ました
それからというものその先生との交流は続き私を心配してくれてわざわざ故郷まで来て
くれたんです
ですがあるとき
連絡が来なくなったのです
体調が悪いなるかな
思っていて
ヶ月
あの言葉を聞きました
メッセをはなくなったんだよ
悲しくて悲しくて黙らないんですもう何位だが出てしょうがないんです
どれまで私にいろんな経験をしてくださっていろんなアドバイスを下さって素敵な経験
をくださった
何私は何も音開始ができなかったですね
その自分に対する怒りそして悲しみ
私はその時学びました
一つ一つの出会いを大切にして
で日々感謝の言葉を言うこと
私は大学生になりましたその時アルバイトを始めたんです
昼間にこの練習をしたかったので深夜バイトです
ですが
7倍とがブラック企業
それは後から知りました
この日入れますこの日入れますよね入ってくださいすごいですねブラック企業というの
は私はそれに負けてしまったんです
自分で決めたにも関わらず
意思の弱い自分が悪い
と思いながらそのバイト1年間続けました
宮城 by 通して
そのままが攻撃そして授業を受け練習もできないまま
またバイト行くそんな日が続きました
イメージ感といったら
ある日私は
壊れてしまったんですね
バイトをは終わり家に帰る途中に
うんをこんな生活嫌ですもう耐えられないんです
もう何も考えることができない ac サイダーできないんです私は何のために大学に
行ったのか
音楽をしたいからそのためだのに自分の練習さえできない事業もろくに受けられない
もう嫌だもう
そして私は大丈夫台所に行き
そして包丁を持ちましたもうこの生活嫌
家族が止めてくれましたーーー
人に感動を与えるということは
自分自身を大事にするということを自分自身を大事にしなければその体がはなければ人
に感動を与えることなんてできないんです
私はそのときにも学びました
私が考える
安藤とは
喜怒哀楽を感じ
そして心が動くということを
怒ってもいいんです泣いてもいいんです悲しくてもいいですただ忘れないでください
そういった経験があるからあなたは今ここに生きているんですこうやって聞きに来れて
いるんです
といった
うの際さん
の財産がなければ
その一つ一つの喜怒哀楽がなければ
では壊れてしまうんですね
足が今使命だと思っていることそれが私が経験した喜怒哀楽そして二世
それを音にして
音馬にして表すということ
あなたがた1人が喜怒哀楽を感じそれが感動
この感動が積み重なり
このの故郷
それができるんです
私の音楽でそして言葉で
一人ひとりの心の故郷に抜けばいいなと思っています
[音楽]
ん
[笑い]
[音楽]
んあ
ん
ni
[音楽]
ブーム
4日
[音楽]
宇宙を
[笑い]
[音楽]
うん
うんブーム
[音楽]
ございました